what we're going to do in this video is
talk about the idea of a sampling
distribution
now just to make things a little bit
concrete let's imagine that we have a
population of some kind let's say it's a
bunch of balls each of them have a
number written on it for that population
we could calculate parameters
so a parameter you could view as a truth
about that population we've covered this
in other videos so for example you could
have the population mean the mean of the
numbers written on top of that ball you
could have the population standard
deviation you could have the proportion
of balls that are even whatever these
are all population parameters
now we know from many other videos that
you might not know the population
parameter or it might not even be easy
to find and so the way that we try to
estimate a population parameter is by
taking a sample
so this right over here is a sample of
size n sample
of size
n
and then we can calculate a statistic
from that sample based on that sample
maybe you know we picked n balls from
there and so from that we can calculate
a statistic
that is used to estimate this parameter
but we know that this is a random sample
right over here
so every time we take a sample the
statistic that we calculate for that
sample is not necessarily going to be
the same as the population parameter in
fact if we were to take a random sample
of size n again and then we were to
calculate the statistic again
we could very well get a different value
so these are all going to be estimates
of this parameter
and so an interesting question is is
what is the distribution of the values
that i could get for these statistics
what is the frequency which which i
could get different values for the
statistic that is trying to estimate
this parameter and that distribution is
what a sampling distribution is
so let's make this even a little bit
more concrete
let's imagine where our population i'm
going to make this a very simple example
let's say our population has three balls
in it one
two
three and they're numbered one
and three and it's very easy to
calculate let's say the parameter that
we care about right over here is the
population mean and that of course is
going to be 1 plus 2 plus 3 all of that
over 3 which is 6 divided by 3 which is
2. so that is our population parameter
but let's say that we wanted to take
samples let's say samples of two balls
at a time and every time we take a ball
we'll replace it so each ball we take it
is an independent pick
and we're going to use those samples of
two balls at a time in order to estimate
the population mean so for example this
could be our first sample of size two
and let's say in that first sample i
pick a one and let's say i pick a two
well then i can calculate the sample
statistic here
in this case would be the sample mean
which is used to estimate the population
mean and in this for this sample of 2
it's going to be 1.5
then i can do it again
and let's say i get a 1
and i get a 3. well now when i calculate
the sample mean
the average of 1 and 3 or the mean of 1
and 3 is going to be equal to 2. let's
think about all of the different
scenarios of samples we can get and what
the associated sample means are going to
be and then we can see the frequency of
getting those sample means
and so let me draw a little bit of a
table here
so
make a table
right over here and let's see these are
the numbers
that we pick and remember when we pick
one ball we'll record that number then
we'll put it back in and then we'll pick
another ball so these are going to be
independent events and it's going to be
with replacement and so let's say we
could pick a 1 and then a one we could
pick a one then a two a one and a three
we could pick a two and then a one we
could pick a two and a two a two and a
three we could pick a three and a one a
three and a two or a three and a three
there's three possible balls for the
first pick and three possible balls for
the second because we're doing it with
replacement and so what is the sample
mean in each of these for all of these
combinations
so for this one the sample mean is one
here it is
1.5 here it is 2 here it is 1.5 here it
is 2. here it is 2.5 here it is 2. here
it is 2.5
and then here it is three
and so we can now plot the frequencies
of these possible sample means that we
can get and that plot will be a sampling
distribution of the sample means so
let's do that
so let me make a little
chart right over here a little graph
right over here
so these are the possible
possible
sample means we can get a 1 we could get
a 1.5 we could get a 2 we could get a
2.5 or we can get a 3.
and now let's see the frequency of it
and i will put
that over here
and so let's see how many ones out of
our nine possibilities we have how many
were one
well only one of the sample means was
one and so the relative frequency if we
just said the number we could put we
could make this line go up one or we
could just say hey this is going to be
one out of the nine possibilities and so
let me just make that
i'll call this right over here this is
one
ninth
now what about 1.5
let's see there's
one two of these possibilities out of
nine so 1.5 it would look like this
this right over here
is 2 over 9.
and now what about 2
well we can see there's one
two
three so three out of the nine
possibilities we got a two so we could
say this is two or we could say this is
three ninths which is the same thing of
course is one third
so this right over here is 3 over 9
and then
what about 2.5
well there's two 2.5 so two out of the
nine times
another way you could interpret this is
you have a when you take a random sample
with replacement of two balls you have a
2 9 chance of having a sample mean of
2.5
and then last but not least
right over here there's one scenario out
of the 9 where you get 2 3 so 1 9.
and so this right over here this is the
sampling distribution
sampling
distribution
for
the
sample
mean
for
n equals 2 or for
sample size
sample
size
of 2.